Paul whether one is a new filmmaker or
more seasoned mm-hmm what would you
advise in terms of the best practices
for submitting to film festivals what
are some of your sort of quick and dirty
little cheat sheet cliff notes that you
would give someone well they're
different for seasoned filmmakers versus
new filmmakers if you've been on the
circuit before it's far easier to
navigate the circuit I think with with
our first film that we did it on the
circuit 10:00 till noon we spent like
three thousand dollars in submission
fees flash-forward to favor which is the
third villain in the circuit I think we
spent like $300 in submission fee it's
like you just once you when you're an
unknown commodity you go out you have to
pay full fees and to everybody but when
you've been around the circuit before
and you play other festivals you can
always write to them ask for waivers
they don't always give them to you but
often they do or at least a discount and
the Austin Film Festival once you've
played there you get a $25 $25 to submit
again late early whatever it's a flat
fee that's a huge savings if they're
late fees like a hundred bucks something
like that with favor playing Weaver my
actor had been in the Austin Film
Festival for so I was able to to get
that that alumni fee so you can you can
save a lot of money that way so that's
different
once you played it before you have an
advantage you're known you can get
around the entries but even if you're a
first-time filmmaker a couple things you
should do one submit early submitting
late is always more expensive and your
odds of getting in are far lower they
start programming right away so you want
to get in the door you if you submit
early and they like your film they're
gonna mentally put you on the schedule
if you submit late and they like your
film they have to like your film better
than something else they've already
manually put on the schedule so you go
in early you're not being graded on a
curve you go in late you are just the
way it is but also the submission fee
difference between early and late are
astounding like I think early average
view early like 50 bucks average for you
late fees a hundred bucks I mean it's
crazy so submit early and then be wise
about where you submit you know I just I
think that if you have a $5,000 feature
with no stars and you have no
connections
it's film festival don't submit to the
Sundance Film Festival it that makes no
sense and don't be like well you never
know
know you know you do know you're not
getting in especially if you submit late
because their programs setting in
mid-july you know all this up most of
the submissions come in in a September
when everybody's rushing to get it you
know under the under the wire you have
no chance the schedule is set you're
literally a hundred twenty-five dollars
to pay for Laurence Fishburne's hotel
room that's literally what you're doing
out of the goodness of your heart and
you're sitting on a coaster of your
movie - for the cold drinks that's
basically about it and you know this
would be why isn't you know do your
homework a good thing to do is if you're
thinking of something to a festival and
I know there's a lot of legwork but what
you do is go to the website of that
festival and look at the previous year's
program if they're playing nothing but
Cuban American films as the Miami Film
Festival does and your film takes place
in Saskatchewan don't submit there maybe
you thought that maybe you should submit
to the Fort Lauderdale Film Fest which
is a wider program you know some
programs have certain specific directors
or tastes if you've made a mumblecore
film don't submit to Fantastic Fest you
know it's be wise
you're a good batting average for
getting in if vessels is about 25%
that's pretty strong so for a first
filmmaker so if you wanted to get the
ten film festivals you had to submit to
40 submit early don't be afraid to write
for waivers if you know somebody or know
somebody who knows somebody you never
know so let's go back to that first-time
filmmaker because it sounds like a lot
of research so should really be put in
did you make like a spreadsheet document
did you were you that organized where
you tracked today I wish we were they
organized we we blundered into it that
was the whole point behind making
official rejection was that hopefully
filmmakers are coming a little bit wiser
we kind of blunder it we can't block
like we'll start with Sundance late and
then we'll Bob scattershot and now a
little more organized about it I think a
good rule of thumb is don't rush to
finish your film finish it
my name's to be finished you know don't
don't don't send an unfinished movie
because you just know they'll check
they'll see the
spirit of it no it's gonna be good when
the cuts done and the mixes they're
looking for any reason to reject your
movie think about when you were casting
your film and you got stacks and stacks
of headshots you like you have one part
you maybe want to read 20 people for the
part you got 400 headshots you're
looking for any reason to get rid of
this you know these people anything
anything that you can do to get someone
off the pilot programmers are not that
different you know if your film isn't
finished with a cuts not quite right yet
they're gonna that's a really good
reason for them to toss it aside and
again unless you know somebody and
they're gonna give you that extra grain
of salt a little bit of attention
there's no point in doing that early so
we de la films finished send it in then
and look at the schedule and say what's
the next if you if you're gonna apply to
major film festivals what's the next to
major film festivals that are coming up
that I can submit early to this Toronto
South by Southwest Sundance slam dance
LA it's out by that's really it but I
start with stop by and I'm a finalist
but those are the ones so if you finish
your film in December well it's too late
for Sundance and slam dance and maybe
even too late for South by so maybe
start start with LA Film Festival and
then Toronto and those are your next two
and then anything after those two if
those two don't accept you you're not
going to get any major film festivals
they're all pretty much the same so or
Tribeca and mag yeah so go ahead and
after that point start looking at
regional film festivals that you've
heard are good and you know you want to
know about film festivals ask a
filmmaker even filmmakers that you don't
know if they're not you know famous
major filmmakers they'll be happy to
write back to you I actually wrote a
blog because I kept any ass with my
favorite film fuzzles we're just listing
here are my favorite festivals here's
why there are my favorite festivals and
there were and there were regional
festivals they weren't like major ones
they're ones that indie filmmakers have
a reasonable shot of getting into if
their films decent I wrote that blog so
I could send it around and would say hey
what's your favorite actual here's a
list you know Phoenix dead center Napa
there's a whole bunch of festivals that
that if you are outside the system and
you don't have major stars in your movie
and you made your film for twenty thirty
thousand dollars
if they like it they'll still play it
you're not running again you know we're
not competing against Robert De Niro
what's the URL it's a as just shut up
and shoot as my is my blog let's talk
about the more seasoned filmmaker what
are some of the politics and etiquette
that one should abide by when going and
asking for a fee being waived or a
lesser fee oh okay um yeah it's a good
question you know I'm actually really a
about it what I do is I think a
really smart thing to do and this is
this in general is this be nice person
and be cooperative and be grateful when
you get into a film festival and be
friendly with the staff film festival
staff aren't that different than any
filmmakers they're just trying to put on
a show and make and you know do their
that's it I mean then your same thing
you're doing so there's a lot of I find
a lot of common ground with that so you
know you're you've been some cat you and
cast in their festival be cool don't be
a dick go down there shake their hand
buy them a drink ask how you can help
and let that a help extend past the end
of the festival friend make friends them
on Facebook get their email address and
then when your new films ready say hey I
know I just want you know my new films
just just completed and we're looking at
the schedule we'd love to be able to
play your festival again we're gonna be
submitting so usually they'll they'll
they'll uh they'll say yeah well don't
pay a fee whatever you do
here's a waiver fees often they'll
they'll ask sometimes so I'll do that
and almost always they'll offer if they
don't offer that I might say well a
possible we can get a maybe a discount
can then then they'll go oh yeah you can
get a waiver and or the or some what's a
discount
Blayne weaver I know outright asks
because you CC me on the emails to
Austin can we get a fee waiver I'm much
more of a security cat about it and
actually if I wasn't friendly with the
staff I we played for example official
rejection played the waterfront Film
Festival which I'd heard great things
about but it was a schedule the exact
same weekend as the dead-center Film
Festival which had already committed to
going to so I didn't get to go to
Waterfront
we played both vessels but no one was at
waterfront and I was a dead center
when favor came around I'm like whomps
and manga waterfront again cuz again
I've heard good things
submitted to waterfront and I couldn't
just write them and go hey can I get a
waiver cuz I didn't show up the last
time I mean I told though I wasn't
showing up it wasn't a surprise but I go
so I paid the full fee and now we got in
and I did go this time and they were
like you're so cool for pay the fee like
we respected you so much more for paying
the fee because you didn't have to you
could have got a waiver I'm like didn't
feel like I had I didn't feel like I
could ask that of you but
you